nine seconds
that's what I'll give you to decide your
fate
[Music]
Roberto tell me what did you do back
home
government work I'm retired because of
these people I'm beginning to understand
real people they see you as one of us
now
if this is where I'm supposed to be
this happens in many times
the mafia
they like cancer
no cure
whatever you and your friends do do it
somewhere else you learn English I'm
preparing
is that a Time ax no it's a burger
you seem like a man who understands
violence
[Music]
I like this place you can't take that
from me
I can take anything I want
but
we found multiple dead bodies on that
farm in Sicily did you kill him
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]